hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see Star Wars
Episode seven this weekend maybe once
maybe like five times but I thought it'd
be fun to do a video just about the dark
side of the force and the state of the
things in the new trilogy versus what
happened in the past we are gonna be
talking about spoilers from the movie so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet we're gonna be talking about
that Knights of Ren the Sith and just
the dark side of the force in general so
I'm gonna start with this quote from Maz
Kanata she kind of sets the stage for
what's going on with the dark side of
the force and just evil in general in
the galaxy she's about a thousand years
old as told by Han Solo and says I've
seen darkness take many forms the Sith
the Empire now it's calling itself the
first order now the first order in the
Knights of Ren are two completely
different things the thing of them is
sharing the same type of relationship
that assisted with the Empire like the
Emperor was part of the Sith he created
the Empire that's why I feel like Snoke
is associated with the Knights of Ren
who led to the creation of the first
order now obviously there's a lot we
don't know about snow we know less about
him than almost any other character
right now it's kind of the same way
after episode 4 after a new hope we
really didn't know anything about the
Emperor either only the Darth Vader this
you know seemingly really powerful evil
person had a master himself so in the
movie Snoke says even you master of the
Knights of Ren haven't faced a test like
this before
Rey has that force vision when she
touches the lightsaber there shows her
kylo ren's characters surrounded by a
bunch of dark figures I think those are
the Knights of Ren the actual people
that are part of the Knights of Ren so
what I think JJ Abrams has done is move
things away from George Lucas's reliance
on the Sith as a group of dark side
force users it's like the way different
religions of real world earth described
their ultimate deity like everyone has a
slightly different description different
interpretation of religion but I still
think it all flows from the same source
and remember Luke was trying to find the
original Jedi Temple now in the expanded
universe there's actually a story about
the beginning of the Jedi but they
throughout the expanded universe so we
can't really use any of those stories as
theory crafting like whatever they're
doing with this new trilogy completely
different from what the comics did with
the origin of the Jedi so here's my
question for you guys let me know in the
comments below do you think that supreme
leader Snoke and Luke Skywalker is part
of like the arc of the force in the new
trilogy or on
similar paths like their story will get
back to the origins of the Jedi and the
origins of the force when you look back
to the original trilogy like what would
Emperor Palpatine have done if he had
truly conquered the galaxy in eradicated
the Jedi will you have seen a new order
of Sith rise up or would it have
remained the George Lucas rule of two
thing he/she dies didn't know - whenever
George Lucas sold Lucasfilm to Disney
one of his conditions was that he would
be allowed input on the new films so he
gave an outline for the new trilogy and
it was only read by like the top three
Disney executives only three people at
Disney read George Lucas's plans for the
new trilogy they ultimately decided to
throw that out and that that's when they
decided to kind of throw out the
expanded universe - and go in a
different direction
you have the Knights of Ren instead of
the Sith here the resistance instead of
the rebellion I'm actually I'm fairly
fascinated to find out exactly what was
in George Lucas's outline but largely
most people think that it was just more
focused on younger characters just like
the prequels were focused on younger
characters so by all accounts I think
the Lucasfilm story group did the right
thing when they got rid of George
Lucas's ideas I mean they also kind of
threw the Sith out and - in terms of
like a bad group of dark side force
users but now we have this new group to
learn about so presumably in like you
know 20 years or however longer it takes
for them to make a new trilogy we might
even see like a new interpretation of
the dark side of the force
made no mistake episode 9 is not going
to be the last saga film they're gonna
make a new Star Wars film every single
year till the end of time and when I say
saga films I'm just talking about main
trilogy you have like the spin-off films
like rogue one that'll be next year
those will fill in the gaps between saga
films and if you guys didn't know
Kathleen Kennedy did say that these new
Saga films episodes 7 8 9 we'll follow
the Skywalker family so when you're
thinking about character backstories
just think about the Skywalker family
being very very important I know we're
all still wondering who Rey is and then
there's really like a couple of really
clear choices you know
is she a Skywalker is she is solo is she
somebody completely different I feel
like any direction they go is fine
because her character is so amazing
though that you might not even care by
the time they actually explain it like
you just be so in love with Daisy Ridley
that's what I feel like these new films
get right that the prequels did not even
if you like the spectacle of the
prequels like there were some amazing
big scenes in the prequel some really
cool stuff that happened I feel like the
characters just weren't there in the way
they are in these new films but back to
kylo Ren master of the Knights of Ren is
there anybody who feels like this new
trilogy isn't all about the redemption
of kylo Ren I mean obviously it's a much
bigger story than that but that's the
central family arc bring Ben home and
who else just loves that he's named
after Ben Kenobi is a perfectly time
bomb to blow up your heart I kept
wondering what kylo Ren's real name was
gonna be you know I was so happy when I
heard Han Solo call that out I mean
obviously it comes before a really cry
worthy scene but it was such a perfect
moment so moving to Episode eight
territory we're probably gonna see a lot
more of the actual Knights of Ren
because Supreme Leader Snoke is going to
be finishing kylo Ren's training and as
much as Episode seven rhymed visually
and thematically with Episode four I
feel like episode eight is gonna be
uncharted territory so don't expect it
to follow the story beats of empire as
much as Episode seven follow the story
beats of episode four I am so excited to
see what Rian Johnson does through these
characters and Daisy Ridley is actually
said that she's read the episode eight
scripts so the script is done and
they've already filmed again you know
that place where Luke Skywalker where
Rey's character finds Luke Skywalker
they've already been back there to film
scenes for Episode eight would you not
be so upset if they just skipped over
that last moment with Rey trying to hand
the lightsaber back to Luke like if they
just jump forward in time three months
he'd be like oh my god what happened
so I am expecting episode eight to pick
up almost immediately after the end of
episode seven and a lot of you guys are
asking if Supreme Leader Snoke is
connected to Emperor Palpatine
if Emperor Palpatine was the Emperor of
the galaxy and one of the most powerful
darkside force users of all time then
how could smoke all be you know very
powerful person himself have absolutely
no knowledge of him so I think that in
the movies they will reference Palpatine
but my understanding based on what JJ
Abrams has said is that Snoke doesn't
have any kind of connection with
Palpatine so that's why I don't think
he's Darth Plagueis or anybody from the
expanded universe
you know everybody wanted to know if he
might have been Plagueis like secretly
some other figure who was behind
Palpatine I think that he definitely is
bigger than Palpatine but I think that
the context is very different I think
what JJ Abrams wants to say is that
Palpatine was just like a small part of
the pie that is the
so definitely expect them to reference
darth sidious in this it but but I don't
think that their plans have anything to
do with what the Sith were doing what
I'm probably gonna do next this week
just because you know hopefully most of
you have seen the movie bite by sometime
next week cuz I'm gonna do bonus videos
for some of the big characters in the
film I could spend all day talking about
these characters there's this so awesome
that the new characters way more
interesting than the original trilogy
characters in the movie so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
in the imax gift certificate giveaway is
still going on right now all you have to
do the end of that is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video real
simple I'll do a Q&A video really soon
we're all announce the winner of that in
case you guys haven't seen it I did do a
full review of the movie you can click
here for that and you can click here for
the 12 days of Deadpool just doing a
whole bunch of Deadpool videos before
the new trailer comes thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you